Musik
Selbst eingespielt. Herzlich willkommen. Herzlich willkommen zu Das Podcast-UFO. Zu dieser fantastischen neuen Folge 133. Ich glaube, du weißt, was das heißt. Lustige Folge? Richtig. Vielen Dank an Moritz für dieses fantastische Info. Ich dachte, es wäre selbst eingespielt. So wirklich mit der Klavierlehrerin daneben, die die Partitur ausgedruckt hat und dann das Handy daneben hält. Aber dann am Ende kamen diese Effekte. Das war gut, das war richtig gut, das hat nochmal so richtig Pep reingebracht. Aber jetzt erfahre ich mich, ob es digital ist oder nicht. Moritz, kannst du ja mal schreiben, ob das digital ist, das ist ein großes Rätsel für mich. Wie war das bei dir? Du hast ja auch Musikunterricht genommen. Ich habe Gitarrenunterricht und E-Bassunterricht und Gesangsunterricht gehabt. Und wie war das so, hat dann dein Lehrer gefragt, deine Lehrerin so, und was würdest du gerne als nächstes spielen? Dann hat der Lehrer schon so dieses Zittern, dieses zittrige Auge, dieses Nichts der White-Werben, nichts der White-Werben. So ein furchtbarer Popsong, den ich mir erst anhören muss. Aber Stefan, also es ist ja wichtig, dass du lernst, was du lernen willst. Also klar, es gibt viele populäre Songs in Charts, aber es gibt auch viel irgendwie aus dem 17. Jahrhundert, Francisco Targa, Fernando Caroli irgendwie, vielleicht gefällt dir da ja was. Ich habe mich meistens untergeordnet, ich habe mich meistens den klassischen Noten der Gäste. Ja, wirklich? Ja, ich glaube, ich war auch in diesem... Ich war aber auch eher so, die waren nicht so, was willst du das Nächste machen, so waren die gar nicht so modern, die haben mir so drei Umschläge zugeschoben, mit dem Konterfeil von Bach, Wagner und Brahms drauf. Und in einem war der Song. Ja, und in einem war dann tatsächlich doch Green Day. Aber eigentlich hatte ich diese Wahl nie.
Hattest du die Wahl? Das war eine moderne Progression.
Naja, was heißt Wahl? Ich glaube, mein Musiklehrer hat das so wie Natalie Portman.
Einen für sie, einen für mich.
Und ich glaube, ich war in dem Ein-für-mich-Jahr.
Und ich war in dem Jahr, wo wir wirklich so barocke Fugen gespielt haben auf der Gitarre.
Und du denkst dir so, ja, es gibt da diese Nina in meiner Klasse, die mag ich. Inwiefern hilft mir dieser barocke Walzer jetzt gerade? Und dann der Lehrer so, wieso hasst sie barock, hasst sie die barocke Zeit? Dann ist Nina es nicht wert. Nina ist eine Zeit nicht wert. Schieß Nina in des Windes. Wenn du alt klingen willst, ist mein Trick immer den Genitiv benutzen. Es macht selten Sinn, aber es klingt immer ein bisschen altertümlicher. Ich kann mich noch an eine obskure Situation aus meiner Kindheit erinnern, wo... Eine. Du kannst dich an eine obskure Situation in der Kindheit erinnern. Das andere ist einfach nur wie so ein trübes Glas, wo man so fragt, ist das ein Mensch, ist das ein Hund? Wie bei Vergewaltigungskindern. Und es gibt ja, also Schule ist ja gleichzeitig cool und nicht cool. Es ist ein ganz merkwürdiges Zwischenfeld. Zum Beispiel gibt man, also ich war auf dem Gymnasium, du ja auch, und da gibt man ja manchmal an, wenn man noch Freunde hat, zum Beispiel aus dem Kindergarten, die nicht auf dem Gymnasium sind, dann sagt man so, wir können schon lesen, wir können schon Bruch rechnen. Das, was man hasst den ganzen Tag über, mit hasserfülltem Auge gerade so durchsteht, wird dann nach der Schule cool, so, oh, wir können schon lesen, so. Das ist so ein komisches Zwischenverhältnis, oder kennst du das nicht? Ja, na ja, ist es nicht menschlich, mit dem, was man hat, was man dann kann, auch anzugeben? Ja, aber man hasst es halt, man hat den Draufschaffprozess, den hasst man. Aber den dann bra Ja, aber man macht es ja, und ich glaube, wenn man das dann macht überhaupt, dann nur zum Bragen, rum Bragen. Nee, aber damit du die Klasse bestehst. Ja, und alles andere ist ja scheissegal. Ja, aber warum bestehst du denn die Klasse? Warum bestehst du überhaupt die Schule? Warum gehst du auf die Schule? Weil du musst, Stefan. Um vor deinen Eltern zu Bragen. Dein Monolog führt zu nichts, es ist einfach Gesetz, Stefan. Wir sind kein landromantischer Monologe, Stefan, es ist einfach Gesetz.
Nach 133 folgendem auch nicht mehr, was ich noch sagen soll.
Und dann irgendwann weiß man halt schon, wenn man das Wort Bragg benutzt.
Ab dem Moment wusste ich schon, dass das nirgendwo hinführt.
Aber es ist einfach so amivalent. In der Schule findet man sein Wissen uncool, ausserhalb der Schule findet man es cool.
Und ich weiß noch, ein Freund von mir, mit dem ich immer nach Hause gelaufen bin, auch so ein Thema,
er hat eine große Schwester und er hat dann immer durch seine große Schwester eingegeben, so meine große Schwester kann schon das und das. Oh, das kenne ich aber, das kennt man ja auch. Und wir haben gerade die vier Fälle gelernt, die da lauten. Das Geisterschloss. Der verschwundene Toast. Der verschwundene Toast. Bernd Briegel wohnt jetzt nebenan und sieht verdächtig aus. Tod in Reihe drei. Genau, Mord auf dem Schlachthof. Und dann hatten wir so die vier, und dann sind wir an so einem Schild vorbeigelaufen auf dem Schulhof, auf dem Nachhauseweg, und da stand Vorsicht vor dem Hunde. Ja, dem Hunde. Und dann hat mein Freund gesagt, ah, das ist der neunte Fall, den hat meine Schwester schon in der Schule gelernt. Den neunten? Und ich so, wow, what up! Erstmal, wenn es einen neunten Fall gibt, wo ist Fall fünf, sechs, sieben und fucking acht? Was ist da los? Gut, wir alle kennen den Vokativ, haben wir letzte Woche darüber gesprochen, zu lange darüber gesprochen. Den gibt es noch, dann gibt es den noch einen, da gibt es aber noch einen im Lateinchen. Imperativ? Ja, das ist ein Fall. Ist das schon ein Fall? Detektiv? Superlativ, Komparativ, Tiefe gibt's viele. Es gibt eine Menge Tiefe, da sind wir uns klar. Im Lateinischen gibt's auf jeden Fall fünf, sechs. Gerund gibt's noch. Gerundium. Gerundiv. Eher dem. Du fängst jetzt nicht an, ein deutsches LK zu googeln. Was hast du gegoogelt gerade? Kasus, Kasi. Das sind Taschenrechner, Stefan. Und zwar gibt's... Was soll das sein? Nominativ, Genitiv, Dativ, Akkusativ, Ablativ. Ablativ. Ablativ. Um einen Denar. Ist das Beispiel. Ja, gut. Aber das ist genau, wie Lateiner funktionieren. Leute, die Latein in Perfektion können, so dass sie dann einen Wikipedia-Eintrag schreiben können, deren Beispiel ist das Erste, was dir einfällt. From the top of my head, um einen Denar. Benutze niemals Denar in Beispielsätzen. Wenn sie zum Beispiel, also dieser Beispielsatz soll einem helfen,
das einem zu veranschaulichen.
Ja, ich denar, du denar,
um einen denar, denarat,
denaramus, übrigens, passt ganz gut, ich lehre gerade
Französisch. Deswegen ist das deinem Tod.
Ich habe mir so eine Französisch-Lehrende runtergeladen.
Und irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, was mit der
App falsch ist, aber ich kriege
so krass depressive Beispielsätze.
Ich weiß nicht, was da los ist. Letztens habe ich die Verneinung gelernt, ne, nö, pa. Und dann habe ich die Verneinung gelernt mit so Sätzen wie Niemand wollte zu meiner Geburtstag herkommen. Holy fuck! Ich mir denke so, mein Bruder mag mich nicht. Nein. Ich mochte das Essen nicht. Immer nur so extrem Ich we weiß nicht, was ein Dinar ist. Nur so depressive
Sätze und das macht einen echt fertig, wo man
so denkt, wenn es schon egal ist,
welchen Satz du verwendest, dann
benutzt es doch positive, um die Leute dran
bleiben zu lassen. Das beschreibt ganz
gut, wie wir beide funktionieren. Die letzte
App, die ich mir runtergeladen habe, ist The Wizarding
World of Harry Potter.
Und jetzt muss ich mir
ein Anlagemodell vorstellen.
Und zwar, ich lege jetzt immer dahin
mein Geld an, von dem ich
Vielen Dank. Walter, Harry Potter. Und jetzt muss ich mir ein Anlagemodell vorstellen. Und zwar, ich lege jetzt immer dahin mein Geld an, von dem ich, weil ich dachte mir vorher, vor Pokémon Go dachte ich mir, wenn man so ein bisschen bei Reddit unterwegs ist und so, und so ein bisschen die Popkultur aufsaugt, nur zum Teil. Ich kratze nur an der Oberfläche der Blase, einer großen Popkulturblase. Und da hat man schon gemerkt, alle Leute warten auf Pokémon Go damals. Dann kam es raus und die Aktie von Nintendo ist in den Himmel geschossen. Warum? Warum kaufen nicht vorher alle, warum ist die nicht vorher in den Himmel geschossen? Weil vorher alle Nintendo-Aktien kaufen, weil das das Normalste der Welt ist. Ja, weil es auch fliegt. So einfach funktioniert der Aktienmarkt, okay. Und bald kommt nämlich das Gleiche von Pokémon Go, bringt Niantic nämlich raus für Harry Potter. Ich habe mir jetzt ganz viele Time Warner Aktien gekauft, für die Warner Brothers, weil die die Lizenzen haben zu Harry Potter. Moment, es gibt ein Pokémon Go für Harry Potter. Genau, da musst du dann ... Hermine fangen oder was? Gegen Dementorenkampf fangen und so, du bist wahrscheinlich einer mit der Häuser und so. Ist schon ganz cool. Ich glaube, es wird der neue heiße Scheiss. Und deswegen habe ich mir jetzt Warner Aktienktien gekauft. Nur mal so zum Scheiss. Wenn das jetzt funktioniert, bin ich dann der Einzige, der der Aktien verstanden hat, oder ist es wirklich so einfach? Es macht nur niemand. Ist es so einfach? Ich denke immer noch gerade darüber nach, was uncooler ist, Pokémon oder Harry Potter, aber ich bekomme es zu keinem Ergebnis. Es ist schon beides ganz cool. Ich glaube, es ist beides ganz, ganz weit unten. Ich weiß nicht. Es ist wirklich ganz weit unten. Ah, ich weiß nicht. Aber Warner, die machen auch Filme, ne? Ja. Jetzt kommt der bald so eine Herr der Ringe Serie raus. Wirklich, ja. Aber ich glaube, die hat überhaupt nichts mit Warner zu tun. Oh, von daher. Lass mich denn mal kurz, wo wir gerade bei dem Thema sind. Ich dachte immer, ich pitch dir mal eine Fantasy-Sage. Sagst du mal einfach mal, was du machst, davon hältst du. Einfach mal so. Es gibt einen Zwergenkönig zum Beispiel, und der findet dann ganz viel Gold. Und dann macht er einen Ring. Und durch diesen Ring kannst du, pass auf, die Welt beherrschen. Mega, oder? So fängt es an. Einfach so. Einfach so. Du kannst die Welt beherrschen. Wie machen das? Durch diesen Weiseln, die Magie.ie. Ist ein Fantasy-Universum. Dann gibt es so einen Menschengott,
und der klaut dann diesem Zwergenkönig,
klaut er dann einfach den Ring,
weiss aber nicht, dass da dieser Fluch drauf ist.
Und der ist mittlerweile auch verkommen.
Der ist so eine kleine Kreatur,
die sozusagen ein bisschen zwiespältig spricht,
also sozusagen ein bisschen schizophren ist,
weil der Ring den mittlerweile eingenommen hat,
weil er halt so viel Macht hat. Es gefällt auch irgendwann dieser Satz, der Herrscher des Rings ist auch der Knecht des Rings. Und dann tatsächlich, irgendwann schafft es dann der Gott der Menschen sozusagen, schafft es dann mit dem Schwert den Ring von der Hand des Zwergenkönigs abzuschlagen. Der wurde auch gestohlen vom Zwergenkönig, vom Menschengott. Genau, und der Menschen, nee, der Zwergenkönig hat den anderen Leuten gestohlen, den Naturgeistern und so ein Kram, aus dem Fluss. Die Naturgeister? Aus dem Fluss. Also er hat ihn nicht selber gemacht, sondern der Zwergenkönig hat ihn geklaut. Aus dem Fluss hat er ganz viel Gold geklaut und hat dann daraus einen Ring gemacht. Gut, und von dem Zwergenkönig hat ihn dann der Menschengott geklaut. Genau, Menschengott geklaut. Jetzt hat ihn der Menschengott. Weil der Menschengott beraten wurde vom Zauberer. Der Zauberer hat ihm gesagt, du musst dem Dieb das stehlen, was er gestohlen hat. Stiehlt dem den Ring. Der Menschengott hat den Ring. Und bezahlt damit jetzt zwei Riesen, die sein Schloss gebaut haben. Und da hat der Hinn eigentlich seine Schwägerin versprochen als Preis. Die wollte er aber nicht abgeben, weil seine Fausen wahnsinnig wütend geworden wäre, und denen gibt er dann diesen Ring, und deswegen erschlägt der eine Riese den anderen Riesen, weil der Ring verflucht ist, so, weil der den trägt, wird böse. Aber es kriegen zwei Riesen kriegen einen Ring, die streiten sich dann, die streiten sich dann, obwohl die einen Riesen im Bonding haben eigentlich, zerschlägt der eine den anderen, so, und der wird dann nach einigen Jahren zu einem Drachen. Der gefallene Riese. Der gefallene Riese nicht, der ist tot. Ah, der ist tot. Der andere hat dann den Ring angenommen, hat sich zurückgezogen. Und der wird zu einem Drachen, weil der Ring den so sehr fein genommen hat. Ja. So. Und in der Zwischenzeit ist der Nachkommen des Menschengottes auf der Welt. So, und der musste dann das Schwert, was zerbrochen ist, als der eine, als der Menschengott den Ring geklaut hat, dem Zwergenkönig, das zerbrochener Schwert, das baut er jetzt wieder zusammen. So, und dieses Schwert, damit schafft er es dann irgendwie den Ring von dem fiesen Drachen zurückzuholen. Das ist so im Kern eine Geschichte. Und kommt dir das irgendwie bekannt vor? Sag mir, wie dir das bekannt vorkommt. Ein zerbrochenes Schwert, ein Drache, der getötet werden muss. Es gibt auch übrigens Elfen, es gibt Naturgeister, es gibt Zauberer, es gibt fucking Zwerge, Menschengötter, dann ein zerbrochenes Schwert, was zusammengesetzt wurde von dem Erben des Menschenanführers. Das ist ich hab's. Das ist diese Fruchtiger-Werbung. Richtig. Wirklich? So, ohne Scheiss. Und zwar wurde das ab einigen Jahren vor Herr der Ringe gemacht. Von Richard Wagner. Oh. Der Ring in die Belungen. Und dann wurde J.R.R. Tolkien gefragt, Alter, hast du das von Wagner geklaut vielleicht? Und er meinte, nö. Zitat, nö. Ja. Ist das zu glauben? Das ist abgefahren. Auf was ich da gestoßen bin? Aber macht der Ring da auch unsichtbar? Nein. Na gut. Naja. Da hast du mich. Nee, aber du kannst durch den Ring deine Form verändern, tatsächlich. Und so bekommen die den auch, weil dieser Zwergkönig erst zu mächtig ist und dann wird er auch so eine große Schlange und so und dann fragen die aber, wow, du bist so mächtig, kannst du dich auch in ein kleines Geschöpf verwandeln, eine Kröte zum Beispiel, dann wird er zu Kröte und dann können die den fangen. Das heißt, der kann schon Formen verändern. Ich finde, da sind so viele Parallelen. Aber auch das mit dem Schwert, aber weiss der Menschenkönig denn, dass er Menschenkönig ist? Das ist ein Gott. Das ist ein Gott, Wotan.
Er weiss das nicht.
Aber der Sohn von dem?
Der Sohn von dem ist Siegmund, und da von dem ist der Sohn Siegfried, der den Drachen tötet.
Ah ja.
Das kennt man dann wiederum.
Es ist wirklich spannend.
Es ist so eine, ich bin wirklich in der Blase, ich habe da so eine Tür aufgestossen und dachte mir, Wahnsinn.
Erstmal ist die Musik total geil, ich bin jetzt, man kann es sagen, in der Wagner-Phase, aber es ist wirklich total spannend und es ist einfach fucking Herr der Ringe und ich kann das nicht vernachvollziehen, warum man da nicht mal drüber gesprochen hat. Aber der Ring der Nibelung sind noch vier Teile, ne? Vier Teile, ja. Also es gibt sozusagen noch einen Bonusteil nach der Rückkehr des Königs. Ich habe gerade ganz schlecht und auch ein bisschen auf Herr der Ringe getrimmt, von Rheingold und Walküre geredet.
Das heißt, es gibt noch drei und vier.
Und Siegfried und Götterdämmerung.
Und es ist wirklich, also der Ringeliebelung wird jedes Jahr aufgeführt.
Das wird da unbedingt hin dieses Jahr.
Nach Bayreuth.
Ja, viel Spaß.
Ist doch nicht so weit weg.
Ja, aber das ist nicht so krass die Meth-Hochburg und da musst du ganz viel Geld haben.
Kommt man da einfach nicht einfach so hin, ne?
Christian Tiedemann ist doch da gerade der Leiter.
Ja, ja, ja.
Es gibt ganz tolle Dokus auf
YouTube anzugucken und ich dachte wirklich
die ganze Zeit, Alter, er zählt Herr der Ringe.
Weil es einfach, die Welt ist die gleiche,
es gibt Elfen, Zwerge, Trolle
quasi, Götter,
Zauberer und so ein Kram und das ist wirklich,
ich fand das unglaublich interessant.
Und es ist nicht so wirklich
wissenschaftlich mal nachgedacht worden,
warum das so ähnlich ist wie Herr der Ringe. Aber Aber ist nicht bei so Opern dann eher so die Geschichte so, man nimmt halt, was gerade rumliegt? Ja, ich meine, die Belungensaga ist ja auch nichts Neues. Aber diese ganze Ringnummer hat er erfunden, der Wagner. Der war der Richard. Der Christian Telemann ist ja auch Dirigent für so Wagner-Opern und der muss mit dem Telefon die Orgel anrufen. Entschuldigung. Das finde ich verrückt. Hallo? Hallo? Ja, genau, ganz kurz, wo Sie es gerade ansprechen. Können wir da vielleicht ein bisschen leiser? Sie sind beim Cello gelandet. Ich verbinde Sie kurz. Vielleicht ein Ticken leiser. Okay, nur ein Hauch. Orgel? Ja,uch, ja, bei der Orgel. Warum muss er die Orgel anrufen? Wo wird denn Orgel gespielt? Die Orgel ist halt irgendwie ganz weit oben oder so in der Kirche. In einer anderen Stadt? Ja, tatsächlich auch. Und dann gibt es ja so eine Szene, die in der Schmiede spielt. Und dann steht da in der Partitur irgendwie so Metallschläge oder Leute hammern auf Metall. Und das haben die auch in so einem Nebenraum gemacht und haben das dann live, aber digital übertragen, wo ich mir dachte, das ist so halb cool. Weil dann kann man es auch aufnehmen und während der auf, aber die müssen jetzt nicht klopfen. Und dann hat er die auch angerufen. Er hatte zwei Telefone, mit einer die Orgel so drei, zwei, eins, Orgel und dann hier so drei, zwei, eins, Hämmer, Hämmer, Hämmer! Aber das ist so cool, einfach, wie so Doktor
Oktopus mit so ganz vielen Telefonen, steuert
der alles. Ja, ich hab mich nämlich gefragt, weil es gibt so eine
Szene, da macht er gerade das Schwertnotung,
was echt
interessant ist zu dem Aragonschwert.
Wie ist Mithrandir? Andruil.
Was ist Mithrandir? Das ist von Gandalf.
Ach so, jedenfalls hat er dann dieses Schwert,
setzt das dann zusammen, um dann den Drachen zu töten,
und da haut er dann mit einem
grossen metallenen Hammer auf das
Schwert drauf. Und das ist halt im Takt
und die Achso, jedenfalls hat er dann dieses Schwert und setzt das dann zusammen, um dann den Drachen zu töten. Und da haut er dann mit einem grossen metallenen Hammer auf das Schwert drauf. Und das ist halt im Takt der Musik. Und ich dachte, das ist gerade schon krass, dass sie von dem Opernsänger erwarten, quasi zu singen und gleichzeitig draufzuhauen. Das ist verrückt. Aber dann macht es wohl einer im Nebenraum. Krass. Aber das ist wirklich, schaut euch mal, lasst uns alle mal, ich meine, wir haben ja auch so einen Bildungsauftrag. Der ganze Podcast-Ufo-Bekanntenkreis, soll man bitte einfach den Ring der lieben Lungen schauen, auf YouTube, einfach mal scheiß, das sind nur 15 Stunden ungefähr, das ist machbar. Und das ist wirklich total spannend, wir sind doch alle Fantasy-Fan. Ey, lass uns einfach mal Folge 134, Antenne andante machen und einfach mal nur Klassik? Nur Klassik machen. Antenne Alberich können wir machen, das ist der Zwergkönig. Das ist doch gut. Antenne Alberich über den König der Ring der Lübelung. Eine komplette Wagner-Folge. Das finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Ja, finde ich auch gut. Ich habe mal gehört, dass die, weil da wird ja sehr wahnsinnig viel gesungen, und ich habe gehört, dass die Sänger sich kaputt singen, dass es so anspruchsvoll ist, dass sie sich wirklich... Am nächsten Tag sind die unglaublich, also man sagt, das ist eigentlich in der Regen-Ernebelung nicht machbar. Es wird ja aufgeführt, also Rheingold ist Vorabend, heißt das, weil Kührenrit ist erster Abend, Sieg wird zweiter Abend, der wird dritter Abend. Das ist ja normalerweise direkt nacheinander alles. Was abgefahren ist, eine krasse Erfahrung, glaube ich. Und das ist eigentlich nicht machbar. Nach einer Wagner-Oper sagen die meisten Sänger muss man eigentlich nicht eine Woche hinlegen,
weil das so verausgabt. Und irgendwie hat mir das den, ich kann das seitdem
nicht mehr voreingenommen hören, wenn man
denkt, also das ist ja auch so,
ich habe mal so einen Vortrag von Christian Thiedemann gehört,
wo der so erklärt hat, dass das dann auch
eine Entscheidung in dem Leben eines klassischen
Sängers ist, wage ich mich an Wagner
oder nicht, weil wenn, bin ich halt ein paar
Jahre durch. Dann habe ich mich halt kaputt
gesungen, aber dafür habe ich halt mal Wagner gesungen.
Und seitdem ist es einerseits
Vielen Dank. Sänger es ist, wage ich mich an Wagner oder nicht, weil wenn, bin ich halt ein paar Jahren durch, so dann habe ich mich halt kaputt gesungen, aber dafür habe ich halt mal Wagner gesungen und seitdem ist es einerseits irgendwie hat es schon was so, dass man sich so aufopfert und sagt so ich opfere jetzt mein Talent dieser Kunst, weil es ist ja auch oft eine Kunst, die nicht bleibt so, wenn du jetzt einen Film drehst und dafür keine Ahnung, was heißt ich, Schmerzen erträgst, dann hast du den Film, aber bei seiner Oper ist es ja oft dann auch vorbei. Und da gibt es dann wahrscheinlich schon Aufnahmen und so.
Ja, wahrscheinlich auch.
Ich meine, die Hardcore-Oper-Fans gehen dann lieber in die Live-Oper.
Deswegen ist es, finde ich, schon so, so Live-Performance hat schon so was. Und dann wird es auch mal geboot, oder nicht?
Ist es nicht in Bayreuth so, dass Andauer geboot wird?
Jedes Jahr wird geboot.
Weiß ich nicht. Kann sein.
Kann auch sein, weil Merkel irgendwo mit drin sitzt.
Und dann sind die ganzen Fotze-Fotze-Leute dann da drin.
Ja, die sich 15 Stunden in die Oper setzen, nur um Fotze zu rufen. Wahrscheinlich. Willst du ja auch nicht haben. Neulich hatte ich so eine ganz komische Erkenntnis, weil da bin ich irgendwie mit Leuten auf die schlimmsten Wörter der deutschen Sprache gekommen. Und wir haben uns entschieden für Titte und Fotze. Titte? Ja, Titte ist schlimm? Nee, ist einfach kein schönes Wort. Ist einfach ein unschönes Wort. Titte. Das klingt einfach kacke. Und Fotze. Und dann hatte ich so einen Geistesblitz. Dass ich genau, mein Name, mein Nachname ist genau die Mischung aus Titte und Fotze. Fitze. Das gibt es überhaupt nicht. Pfeff an Schwitze. Weil man merkt ja, wenn Leute Titze sagen, habe ich immer so ein Zucken geht durch meinen Körper. Ich denke, das ist nicht, so bitte nicht einfach aussprechen. Und jetzt weiß ich auch langsam, warum. Ich habe 23 Jahre gebraucht, jetzt habe ich es herausgefunden, weil es die Mischung aus zwei unschönen Wörtern ist. Hast du manchmal auch so Serienmomente, wo du so plötzlich dein Leben in so einer Dramaturgie siehst? Ja. Und ein wichtiges Element der Dramaturgie ist ja zum Beispiel die Regel, die illustriert wird durch Chekhov's Gun, also die Chekhov's Pistole, dass wenn du im ersten Akt eine Pistole einführst, muss die im dritten Akt auch abgefeuert werden. Rückwirkend, alles was passiert, soll irgendwie eine Connection zu etwas anderem in der Geschichte schon mal haben. Also so, man macht Klammern immer auf und dann wieder zu. Und so habe ich mir zum Beispiel gedacht, ich habe mal eine Frau kennengelernt, und die meinte dann irgendwann so, das schlimmste Wort, was man zu ihr sagen kann, und das hört sie überhaupt nicht gerne, und das ist furchtbar, und da fährt sie durch Mark und Leib, ist eben Forze. Und da ist bei mir sofort die Dramaturgie angegangen, hundertprozentig. Im dritten Akt steigen wir, und ich mache Schluss Schluss und beim Rausgehen sage ich, weißt du was, du Dumme, so. Und dann ist die Klammer zu. Und ich konnte nur daran denken und ich hatte ein Lächeln auf den Lippen und dachte mir, das ist ein geiler Moment, weil jetzt kann man so richtig zumachen. Lächeln auf den Lippen, entweder Soziopath oder Dramaturgie-Liebhaber, Dramaturg. Das vergisst der Zuschauer nämlich und dann am Ende denkt man sich, Zuschauer sind dusselig. Ja, so halbdusselig. Nee, weil man weiß ja noch genau, was gesagt wird. Aber man hat es im Hinterkopf gespeichert. Das ist ja zum Beispiel oft so, man merkt ja an schlechten Filmen, also vor allem an so ganz schlechten Filmen, so Trash-Filmen, ist, dass sie Szenen nie gut beenden können. Es fällt immer sofort auf, wenn Filmszenen nicht beenden, weil dann ist es da so aus, einfach aus. Also die Szene hört auf, eher als dass sie endet. Und eine andere Szene beginnt. Genau. Man fragt sich auch, warum die dann oft da beginnen. Bei schlechten Filmen fragt man sich nicht mehr, warum beginnt da die Szene. Weil meistens zu früh oder zu spät. Und was ja oft bessere Serien dann machen, ist eigentlich ein billiger Trick, aber was man gut machen kann, ist irgendwie so eine Art Pointe einbauen, indem man so ein Callback macht zu irgendwas, was schon am Anfang der Szene aufgetaucht ist, keine Ahnung, sie reden über irgendwas und dann was weiß ich, hast du schon den ganzen Schinken aufgegessen und am Ende kommt dann nochmal irgendwie das so, ich muss jetzt noch einen Schinken kaufen, so ganz billiges Beispiel. Und dann ist es befriedigender, dass die Szene aufhört, weil jede Szene muss mit irgendwas aufhören. Deswegen meine große These, Leute, die Comedy schreiben und vom Sketch kommen, Leute wie Adam McKay zum Beispiel, sind schon defaultmäßig weiter als normale Leute, die gerade erst anfangen, Filme zu machen. Einfach durch eine Sketch-Dramaturgie, weil an Szenen herangegangen wird wie in einem Sketch. Und wenn man Szenen wie Sketcher betrachtet, funktioniert Big Short zum Beispiel mega gut, auch clippig ist er ja auch. Und wenn du dann einfach bei YouTube kannst, kannst du quasi alle Szenen nachgucken, was ja auch für einen Film spricht, wenn Leute Szenen für sich genommen ins Internet stellen, um Leute das, die ja auch geklickt werden, weil die für sich funktionieren, weil die für sich genommen nochmal rewatchable sind und man will die auch nochmal angucken, weil die im Kopf geblieben sind. Da spricht man für einen Film, wenn sehr viele Clips im Internet sind. Und so funktionieren zum Beispiel Adam McKay-Filme total, weil die einfach so sketchy sind. Er macht auch Comedy natürlich, aber es funktioniert auch auf anderen Genres. Und was wichtig ist bei Szenentransitions ist immer, das haben glaube ich die South Park-Macher gesagt, dass du kein Und zwischen den
Szenen hast. Schlechte Filme haben oft
ein, du hast eine Szene A,
dann kommt ein gedachtes
Und zwischen der Szene und dann kommt eine neue Szene.
Und es ist immer boring, weil es wirkt immer
wie eine Aneinanderreihung von jetzt kommt die Information,
die Information und jetzt kommt das Finale
und der Abspann. Und besser wäre ein Weil.
Besser wäre ein Weil, ein Aber,
ein Dennoch, ein Weswegen und so. Alles besser als und. Mähnt sich das. Finde ich gut. Ich glaube auch, deswegen sind so Comic-Relief-Charaktere auch gut, weil die immer am Ende noch mal sowas reinwerfen können. Das ist ja auch, zum Beispiel gerade diese ganzen Superhelden-Filme, auch so Avengers und so, das ist ja fast unerträglich, dieses Schema, wenn es einmal auffällt, dieses man baut Pathos auf, man baut Pathos auf und dann ein frecher Gag und Pathos wieder weg und die nächste Szene ist so. Es gibt immer, ob es jetzt bei Guardians of the Galaxy dieses Tier ist oder Groot oder ob es jetzt irgendwie so ein Tony Stark ist, du hast immer so eine Figur, deren Aufgabe ist es, diesen Pathos zu brechen, weil das immer eine gute Möglichkeit ist, aus der Szene zu kommen. Kommt das nicht aus so einer Familienfilm, wir wollen möglichst eine breite Masse erreichen, dass man sagen, wir wollen keinen Tod, das war ja bei Star Wars The Last Jedi auch oft kritisiert worden, wo auch tatsächlich der Cutter von The Force Awakens hat Rian Johnson einen Tipp mit auf den Weg gegeben für den Postproduktionsprozess, You can't get enough of BB-8. Ah ja. Weil BB-8 ist genau so eine Figur.
Ist genau so eine Figur, ist genau so eine Figur und immer wenn du nicht weißt, was gerade, woran er hinschneiden soll, schnall auf BB-8. Irgendwie so ein süßer Blick oder so. Der hat gerade was zu tun, genau und du kannst dann einfach, also der hat immer irgendein Business am Laufen und ist immer ein Lacher automatisch, weil es ein Ball ist. Ja, aber auch so Figuren wie bei Seinfeld, also Kramer oder so, die halt immer am Ende nochmal,
also der halt nie ganz im Gespräch ist so. Immer so ist,
also der Plot liegt immer bei anderen Figuren,
die reden und das und das und wir müssen das machen
und dann ist der gerade nicht ganz im Gespräch
und läuft da noch was rein.
Ja, aber in Filmen hast du halt dann oft jemanden, weil
Comedy ist ja auch mal das Tanz,
dann hast du oft diesen Comic-Relief-Charakter, der, wie du schon sagst, nicht im Gespräch drin ist. Jetzt können Sitcoms vorwerfen, Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, hat da selten was, der hat keine Stakes so richtig. Und dadurch kann er immer von außen so ein bisschen das Gespräch kommentieren und so eine Szene abrunden. Das ist interessant.
Naja. Das stimmt schon.
Übrigens, ich lerne Französisch
und ich habe irgendwie, es gibt ja tausende
Französisch-Apps und ich
mag eigentlich Apps,
deren Aufgabe sehr
klein ist, die eine Sache
machen und that's it.
Zum Beispiel will ich eine App,
die französische Vokabeln hat und
nur Vokabeln und sonst nichts.
Aber man findet nur diese vollgepackten Apps
Vielen Dank. machen und that's it. Zum Beispiel will ich eine App, die französische Vokabeln hat. Und nur Vokabeln und sonst nichts. Aber man findet nur diese vollgepackten Apps mit, jetzt du hörst den Wort an, du schaust einen kleinen Film an über französische Kultusen, alles scheißegal. Und was diese App, die ich habe, auch hat, ist am Ende jeder Lektion kannst du einen kleinen Aufsatz schreiben und der wird dann online irgendwo hochgeladen, wo ihn andere User der App korrigieren können. Weil das kann ja die App selbst nicht. Das müssen dann Menschen machen. Und das kannst du entweder schreiben oder sagen, diesen Aufsatz. Dann stellt den am Ende so, was hast du gestern gegessen? Und dann halt so ganz trivial, einfach aufzählen, was du gegessen hast. Und irgendein Follycoat muss ich denn anhören. Ich war gestern im Kino und dann habe ich Popcorn gegessen. Und dann hat Popcorn mich gegessen. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Das ist falsch. Falsche Richtung. Und tatsächlich, man muss das machen, um weiterzukommende Lektionen. Deswegen denke ich mir, schreibe ich jetzt da Kauderwels rein. Die App wahrscheinlich. Nee, die hat was gekostet. Ah, okay. Aber, und man kann dann auch immer so,
möchten Sie auch Lektionen von anderen korrigieren?
Nein, nein, nein, auf keinen Fall.
Auf keinen Fall, no way.
Und ich glaube, ich habe die ersten 20 Lektionen nur geschrieben,
Jem Fromage, Jem Fromage, ich mag Käse, ich mag Käse, ist auch falsch, glaube ich, ich mag Käse.
Und wer auch immer meine Lektionen korrigiert, so jede fucking Woche, ich mag Käse, ich mag Käse, ist auch falsch, glaube ich. Ich mag Käse. Und wer auch immer meine Lektionen korrigiert, so jede fucking Woche.
Weiß er mag Käse.
Das ist schon so ein Running Gag.
Ich mag Käse.
Oder so ein Feierabend.
Man hebt dich zum Feierabend auf.
Du hast noch den Käse-Typen, man nimmt dich durch.
Und sich denkt auch so, erstens der Typ lernt nicht, ich schreibe jedes Mal Jem le Fromage dazu.
Und zweitens entwickelt sich auch nicht, weil der bleibt hängen bei diesem einen Satz.
Vielen Dank. lernt nicht. Ich schreibe jedes Mal Jem le Fromage dazu und zweitens entwickelt sich auch nicht, weil der bleibt hängen bei diesem einen Satz. Wir wissen, dass du Käse magst. Aber es ist so spannend, weil ich behaupte, und das weiß ich auch, dass wenn Apps und Programme manchmal behaupten, es gibt dafür einen Algorithmus, es oft einfach Leute in Indien sind. Und da hätten auch Leute behaupten können, unser Algorithmus kann dann deine Aufsätze auf Französisch korrigieren. Und es sind einfach Inder, französisch sprechende Inder. Aber es gibt tatsächlich die Geschichte von einem Arbeitskollegen, der weiß nämlich, weil er Leute kennt, die arbeiten. Amazon hatte mal eine App, da konntest du was, so eine Fotografie-App, du konntest ein Produkt fotografieren und er hat dir einen Algorithmus ausgespuckt, was das für ein Produkt ist und wo du es kaufen kannst und direkt den Amazon-Link natürlich, also wo du es kaufen kannst, Amazon, ob wir es auch schon. Und dann hat er mal, irgendwann war dann dieser Amazon-Mitarbeiter, hat dann gekündigt und so, wegen der schlechten Arbeitsbedingungen, und hat dann halt ab und zu mal beim Glas Wein dann davon erzählt, was da eigentlich so hinter den Kulissen passiert ist. Unter anderem kam dann das Gespräch auf diese App und er sagt, ja, ja, unser Algorithmus. Und tatsächlich mussten dann Inder, ganz viele Inder waren in so einem grossen Gebäude, wo die ganz viele Bilder geschickt bekommen haben von Leuten, die diese App benutzt haben, und die waren dann der Algorithmus. Aber woher wissen die das denn? Kennen die alle Produkte der Welt? Nein, die mussten dann taggen. Die mussten dann einfach, angenommen, wir gucken diese Kopfhörer, fotografieren wir, da steht ja schon mal drauf, AKG. Oder hier steht ja sowas Produktname drauf. Ansonsten schreiben die einfach Black, Headphones, Silver, Music. Und dann hatten die halt, und dann kam der Algorithmus, der eigentliche Algorithmus ins Spiel, der einfach die Tags sortiert und dann wie Suchbegriffe das bei Amazon eingibt. Und dann kommen halt die Produkte, die am ähnlichsten dazu sind. Aber so schnell geht das, weil du machst dein Foto und willst dann sofort die Resultate oder dauert es dann eine Woche oder was. Das ging aber nicht so schnell. Das ist ja super unbefrieden. Und dann hat der Kollege einen Gag gemacht, also er hat keinen Gag gemacht, aber es kam dann als Gag zurück. Er hat dann ein Foto von seinem Kumpel gemacht. Und der Kumpel war ein bisschen fülliger. Und dann haben die das eingeschickt. Und dann musste der Inder halt auch Sachen eingeben. Und da der halt taggt, hat der halt eingegeben Fat Guy, unter anderem wahrscheinlich. Weil das Produkt, was kam, war ein Bauchtrainer, ein Bauchweckgürtel. Wow. Und da muss man auch sagen, entweder haben die einen Scherz erlaubt da, oder die haben einfach Fat Guy eingegeben und dann hat Amazon halt das ausgespuckt. Aber das fand ich so interessant. Und deswegen überlege ich langsam wirklich, gibt es Algorithmen wirklich diese App, die ich hier habe, diese Artificial Intelligence, die mir schreibt. Es ist nicht einfach, sind es nicht einfach Menschen aus Indien, die schreiben? Ja, das kann schon auch sein. Oder nicht? Ich weiß es nicht. Spannend, vielleicht ist alles Inder. Also so, wenn du bei Google was eingibst. Algorithmus ist Inder. Ganz viele Inder, die in Büchern nachschlagen und so, so Zitate oder YouTube. Wikipedia ist ein reines What the fuck, er hat Richard Strauss in Google. Ja, ja, fuck, schlicht, schlicht, schlicht,luss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, schluss, in einer französischen Fabrik gefangen. Aber versuch mal, es zumindest mit denen zu kommunizieren. Hallo, ich frage mich einfach, wo ihr da sitzt. Ja, ja. Bist du ein weiterer User dieser App? Oder bist du ein Inder? Le App? Le Andien. Oder bist du ein Inder? Zu Andy. Le Selandien. Le André. Aber ich denke, was würde wirklich, wenn der entscheidet, Hilfe, ich bin hier gefangen. Ab welchem Punkt wird es ernst? Also würden die dann irgendwann sagen, weil das, da habe ich direkt. Ah, dann frage ich mich. Ich meine, das ist auch noch nicht mehr lustig, da müssen wir nicht drüber reden, das mache ich auch nicht. Aber irgendwo. Wie ist es nicht mehr lustig? Also wenn jemand in der französischen Korrigierfabrik gefangen ist, ist es natürlich lustig. Na, das ist schon lustig, aber jetzt sowas wie Hilfe, ich bin in einem Keller gefangen, rufen sie die Polizei. Das würde ich nicht tun. Ne, das würde ich auch nicht tun. Das ist ja schon klar. Aber das war dann die... Wir drehen aus dem Kreis. Ja, aber das ist... Ich weiß nicht genau. Ich frage mich, also vor allem, wenn er so etwas schreibt, wie Hilfe, ich bin in einer faszinierischen Korregefabrik gefangen, dann würde ich ihm nicht glauben, weil er ist ja offensichtlich auch mit dem Internet verbunden. Ja, und es sagt dann niemand, welchem Keller gibt es... Kellern hast du generell gutes Internet. Das glaube ich nicht. Meinst du? Aber dann kannst du ja auch woanders, dann kann der ja auch wirklich auf einem seriösen Wege Hilfe suchen. Ja. Also über diese App. Naja, er ist ja in der Französisch-Übersetzungsfabrik gefangen. Wenn er ja den ganzen Tag Französisch lernen muss. Ja, aber die werden ja die Krierung mal essen zwischendurch. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie so gute Arbeitsbedingungen haben. Und haben die so einen Hund da rumläuft mit den Schlüsseln im Mund. Ja, ja. Ich überlege es mir noch, ich halte euch auf dem Laufenden, was da alles bei Rom-Com kommt, aber vielleicht lerne ich jemanden kennen. Einfach vielleicht ist es eine interessante, ich denke mir auch zum Beispiel so, ich habe letztens Netflix so eine Rom-Com geschaut und Rom-Com ist ja so ganz, auch so ein klassisches Genre-Ding, wo es halt so Beats gibt, die jede Rom-Com braucht. Richtig. UndCom braucht den Cute Meat, manchmal heißt es auch Meat-Cute oder Cute Meat geht beides. Und das ist halt so in der Art, wie die beiden kochen. Das gibt es in jeder Rom-Com. Cook Meat. Wie sich kennenlernen, auf eine süße Art. Auf eine niedliche Art, ja. Und das ist halt einfach, glaube ich, einfach ein limitierter Pool. Und dann kommt irgendwann wieder so ein Podcast-Lappen wie du, der sagt, nee, der hat geklaut von dem 1970er Mute-Cute, da war es genauso.
Nein, es gibt einfach nur eine endliche Anzahl an Möglichkeiten, wie sich Menschen kennenlernen können.
So, und deswegen müssen die immer kreativer werden.
Und ich schaue eigentlich Rom-Coms ausschließlich mit dem Ziel, welchen... Was mehr schafft sie am kreativsten Cute-Meat einzubauen?
Ja, welchen Cute-Meat haben sie sich überlegt? Ja, und? Sie war Kellnerin im Restaurant, er hat da gegessen. La La Land. Ja. Und alle anderen Filme. Gibt's oft. Oft auch in der Reihe. Jetzt Serie The Sinner, hab ich auch grad angefangen, Netflix, genauso. Da treffen sie sich auch einfach Restaurant. Ja, das ist mir bei Baby Driver extrem nervig aufgefallen. Baby Driver war genauso, auch
Cute Mead im Restaurant. Sie war Kellnerin, er hat da
gegessen. Ich meine, klassische Beispiele,
sowas wie Garden State, wo sie
in diesem Warteraum sind und wo dann der Hund
ihn anrammelt, wo man dann so erst
langsam ins Gespräch kommt über so eine
awkward Situation, schreibt ein Film
auch gar nicht ganz gut, so zwei awkward
Leute finden sich, so da passt das dann ganz gut.
Aber wenn ihr Lieblings Cute Meads habt, schreibt sie mir in die Kommentare. Ich entwickle ja auch gerade eine Serie und das ist wirklich interessant. Auch du meinst im Gegensatz zu mir, der ich komplett arbeitslos bin, oder warum sagst du auch? Wie die Serie, über die wir gerade sprechen. Ach so, ich dachte auf mir, ach so, nee, ich dachte sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, kurz Entschuldigung, bitte natürlich nicht. mach weiter, mach weiter, ich will dich gar nicht stören, ich will dich gar nicht an deinem Ruckzipfel hängen, Stefan, bitte, fahr einfach.
Naja, und da ist es halt auch aufgefallen, dass man halt, Charaktere müssen sich halt irgendwo treffen.
Und dann fällt einem aber auf, sobald der Treffpunkt willkürlich wirkt, sobald irgendeine Variable der Szene willkürlich ist, ist ein Fehler vorhanden.
Weil oft ergibt sich ja aus der Prämisse der Serie erstmal, dann aus den Charakteren und die dann die Prämisse unterstützen müssen. Serien sind ja im Prinzip große Erörterungen von Themen oder Themenkomplexen. Beispiel Homeland geht es nur um Loyalität zum Beispiel. So und alles, jeder Charakter, der nicht dem Thema Loyalität zubringlich ist, dienlich ist, den kannst du killen. Kill die Darlings. Du meinst wie diesen Zauberer in Staffel 3? Ja, der war echt der, wo man sagt, das ist ein Dead-End, Leute, da kommt der irgendwo hin. Oder die Werbung, die manchmal unten reinkommt, von HBO Now. Dieser Buffering da, hello. Das war einfach Quatsch. Nee, und das ist ein Abschalter. Und dann, deswegen sind Orte, wo man sich trifft, sollte man auch einfach als Symbole benutzen. Das habe ich dir noch nie in der Serie vorgemacht. Aber das ist so mein Learning. Gut, okay, dann sage ich dir jetzt einen Ort und du sagst mir, wofür ist dieser Ort ein Symbol. Eisdiele. So, das ist ein Ort für Freizeit. Das ist ein Ort für Kälte. Für, sagen wir mal, das einfache Gefolg, was da einkauft, um mal eine gute Zeit zu haben. Stichwort, meinetwegen sagen wir Leistungsdruck. Das wäre so ein, wenn ich sage, ein Charakter muss die ganze Zeit Leistungsdruck. Pass auf, ein Charakter, der die ganze Zeit arbeiten muss. So, und jetzt soll er, der große Konflikt der Serie ist beispielsweise, dass er eine Frau entdeckt, die meinetwegen keinen Job hat, einen anderen Lebensstil hat und super, weil sie nicht freiheitsliebend ist. Und sein Problem ist die ganze Zeit, er hasst diesen Job. Und jetzt sieht er als Sex-Attract diese Frau, die aber gleichzeitig für mehr steht, für ein Symbol der Freiheit. Dann kann ich mir vorstellen, dass er in dieser Eisdiele, dass er mal einfach in der Eisdiele dackelt und zu sagen, fuck it, ich will nicht mehr in meinem fucking Büro sitzen, ich gehe mal in diese Eisdiele da drüben. Aber warum geht das nicht in der Krepperie? An die ich jeden Tag vorbeigegangen bin. Warum geht es nicht in dem Crepladen? Na gut, jetzt wird es Haarspalterei. Also, ich würde sagen, Crepladen und Eisdiele nimmt es nicht viel. Crepladen geht auch. So, ich finde es beides aber nicht wirklich, weil wir merken, wir schwimmen bei der Eisdiele, also würde ich immer noch sagen, ist noch ein bisschen zu willkürlich. Okay, gut. Wenn er jetzt in der Achterbahn jemanden trifft, fände ich es besser. Ja. An der Achterbahn, an der er jeden Morgen vom Job vorbeigegangen ist, weil er in seinem scheiss Cubicle muss, wo er vor seinem PC sitzt, jeden Morgen um acht Uhr. Er hat keine Dankbarkeit dafür. Und an jedem Tag muss er an diesem scheiss Rollercoaster vorbei, an dem Eingang, und dann geht er einmal da rein und trifft seine Frau. Dann würde ich sagen, okay, das ist ein Symbol. Okay, Ort, Bahnhof. Ja, Fernweh. Das war's von mir, das war die Stephan-Tier. Ihr versteht, worauf ich... Ich verstehe, worauf du erinnerst. Aber ist das so, dass das nicht... Also ja gut, was heißt Austauschbar? Also jetzt zum Beispiel Star Wars. Cantina hätte das auch ein Restaurant sein können. Nee, das glaube ich nämlich nicht. Weil das ist ein super gutes Beispiel. Deswegen, weil das zum ersten Mal... Lucas war in seiner behüteten Familie die ganze Zeit. Der hat noch nie Gefahren gesehen, noch gar nichts, noch nicht mal die wilde Welt. Der war noch nie in dieser Stadt in Mos Eisley, der war noch nie in dieser Kantine. Und das ist einfach sofort der Ort, wo sich, was sagt Obi-Wan? Irgendwie Scum. Ja, Scum rumschlägt aus der ganzen Galaxie. Und er wird angegangen und fast umgebracht, wenn Obi-Wan nimmt ja nicht Hilfe mit dem ... Es ist natürlich ein Ort, wo keine Gesetze gelten, wo Han Solo Greedo erstießt. Also das ist jetzt weniger eine Eisdiele. Ja, wenn das eine Eisdiele wäre, hätte die Szene nicht funktioniert. Anderer Film. Weil das zum ersten Mal, da beginnt der Akt zwei von Star Wars, wo der Held zum ersten Mal sich in die neue Welt wagt. Und das muss natürlich sofort ein Ort sein, wo er mit dem geballten Härte der Galaxie getroffen wird. Und dafür ist es ein super Beispiel. Weil das halt so ein regelloser Ort ist, wo gesoffen wird, wo alle Leute irgendwie, wo das Scum den Leuten hervorkommt. Und wo es kein Eis gibt. Und kein Eis gibt. Da wird ja auch die Abwesenheit von Eis irgendwo definiert. Wenn es dann nämlich Eis gäbe, würde man sagen, bleib auf Tatooine. Ja, ja. fehlt Eis, wenn es da Eis gibt, bleibt da. Wahnsinnig wenig Snacks, ne, also das ist immer so, ich finde so, Science Fiction ist ja auch immer so World Building und so super realistisch. Wenig Snacks. Wenig Snacks. Also zum Beispiel auch sowas wie diese Death Sticks. Was genau ist das? Also ich würde da wirklich, also Star Wars Episode 2, ne, also das ist eine Form von Droge, aber... Du würdest du die nicht nehmen? Ja, ich weiß nicht. Ja, welcher Marketingchef hat gesagt, wisst ihr was, der Sticks ist eine mega, es war immer der gleiche Typ, der auch Todessternen gesagt hat. Ja, und der die SS-Uniform designt hat. Genau. Totenköpfe? Wirklich? Oh, die Piraten. Wollten die wirklich böse sein, wollten die böse wirken, hat der Marketingchef massiv versagt.
Gab es mal ein Land, das seine Flagge bereut hat?
Beireut?
Danke.
Und jetzt gibt es eine neue Szene anfang, weil ich als Dusselier Comic Relief plötzlich einfach nochmal einen Bogen geschlagen habe zum Anfang.
Ja, stellt euch jetzt so eine Kreisschwarzblende vor und dann zieht sie wieder auf und wir sind es in der Eisdiele. Ja, jetzt sind wir in der Eisdiele. Wo würden wir uns treffen? An welchen Ort hätten wir bestimmt? Genau hier, genau an diesem eiförmigen Tisch mit zwei Mikrofonen vor uns. Aber wirklich, es ist ja so Flagge, also oft entstehen ja so weitreichende Entscheidungen in kürzester Zeit. Also so, keine Ahnung, so Revolution, dann Kontrarevolution, dann wird der erschossen, dann wird der erschossen, zack, zack, zack und aus. Und die nächsten hundert Jahre ändert sich gar nichts mehr. Aber davor in kürzester Zeit Flagge so, auch Hymnen, Flagge so, Hymnen, kurz eine Strophe raus, andere Strophe raus, so ein Drum and Bass Ding drunter. So ist ja auch so eine Frage, werden Hymnen irgendwann moderner? Oder bleibt man jetzt für den Rest der Zeit immer auf diesem klassischen Musik-Blas-Orchester, Blasmusik so getragen? Oder sagt man wirklich immer, einfach so mit so einem Drop einfach so. Wir sind die Erste mit Drop. Wir sind die Erste Drum and Bass Land. Die Fidschi-Inseln standen immer schon für Fortschrittlichkeit, für Progressivität. Wir haben den ersten gerappten Song. Aber wer entscheidet, ob die Hymne geändert wird? Das ist so ein klassischer Gesetzesentwurf, Parlament entscheidet, oder braucht man da so eine Sondervollmacht? Da muss der Bundespräsident auf jeden Fall noch die Unterschrift drunter setzen. Und dann einfach sagen, Freunde, jetzt scheiß mal grad auf alles andere. Es ist eine Diskussion, dass die Nationalhymne doof ist, was sie auch verstehen kann.
Ja, aber es wäre doch echt irgendwie verschenkt, wenn man jetzt nur ändert so von Brüderlichkeit, keine Ahnung, weil es ja irgendwie auf die Geschlechter ankommt bei Brüdern, sagt man dann halt statt Brüderlich sagt man swaggig oder halt krass oder sowas in der Richtung.
Aber dann nicht einfach zu sagen, Leute, dann nochmal komplett von vorne denken einfach, dann nochmal irgendwie Beats, vielleicht so ein Featuring, einfach so ein Featuring-Smodo mit rein. Ich finde es zumindest gut, dass bei uns kein Gott drin ist. Also, dass die Religiösität rausgelassen wurde aus der Nationalhymne. Nicht vor Gott sind wir alle gleich und Gott hat uns zum großen Land gemacht. Das muss man schon sagen, da ist die Hymne schon, die Botschaft ist ja nicht schlecht, dieser Strophe. Aber es ist trotzdem irgendwie ... Warum waren Leute dagegen? Da gab es doch neulich so eine Petition, wo man auch sagen, haben Petitionen schon mal irgendwas? Man denkt, ihr sammelt viele Unterschriften, die meisten sind gefälscht, oft ist es nur ein Strich. Was erreicht die wirklichen Petitionen? Ich glaube, das kratzt so ein bisschen an Fake News, diese Nachricht. Aber ich glaube, der Kritikpunkt war, dass es halt, sag ich mal, nicht geschlechterneutral ist.
Also dass du zum Beispiel brüderlich hast, wo man eigentlich brüderlich und oder schwesterlich oder halt dann, wie gesagt,
irgend so ein Mittelwort wie Geili oder irgendwie sowas, als sich dann was überlegen muss, was man dann halt macht.
Klar, warum eine feministische Sache.
Sind es Glückesunterpfand?
Alle Menschen werden Brüder,
wo des Glanzes Flügel
Menschen werden Brüder,
wo dein sanfter Flügel fällt.
Wald.
Waldig fällt.
Fuck, wo dein sanfter Flügel weilt.
Freude schöner Götterfunken, Tochter aus Elysium,
wir betreten Feuer trunken,
Bruder, Bruder, himmlisch wärt dein Heiligtum. Ja, ist gut jetzt. Wir wissen alle, dass du die sechste Klasse erfolgreich bestanden hast, Stefan T. Schon gut. Sag mal. Symphonie Nummer? Neun. Satz Nummer? Vier. Guck mal, wie kann man nichts vormachen? Wir sind doch schon halb eigentlich in Antenne an Dante drin. An Dante, ja, wir sind kurz davor. Wo wir grad bei Französisch waren, übrigens, ähm ... Komische Überleitung, ihr werdet gleich verstehen, warum. Ich hab mich an der Soße ... Was so? Erst dachte ich mich ... Ich dachte so für einen Hauch, jetzt kommt eine Frauengeschichte, aber okay, es geht um die Soße. Ja, na ja, Soße Hollandaise, und zwar ... Das ist die Frau unter den Soßen. Pass auf. Nee, ich hab für einen Abend, da kamen ein paar Freunde zusammen, auch ein paar Frauen. So, und dann dachte ich mir ... Spargelnacht oder was? Ja, mit Spargel, Grillabend. Grillabend mit Spargel. Grüner Spargel dann? Nein, weißer Spargel. Aber grillend immer nur grünen Spargel. Nicht gegrillt. Wir haben den Spargel gemacht, wie man Spargel macht, nebenbei gegrillt. Das war halt das Gemüse zum Grillenfleisch.
Okay, okay, hey, hey. Ich hab, ja, weil du mich anschreitst. Und dann hab ich gedacht, komm, du kannst ja sonst nichts und alle Leute denken, du kannst nicht kochen, steuer ich eine Sauce Rondesse bei. Ja, okay, geschlecht die Idee.
Ja, das, ich war, rückblickend war ich ein richtiger Narr.
Und ich habe es auch schon, ich habe ein Foto bei Instagram gepostet und Leute haben wirklich, also ist eine Wutwelle durch Deutschland gegangen. Es ist noch nie in meinem Leben ist etwas von so liebevoll und so schön innerhalb von wenigen Sekunden in so einen Grauen gewandelt worden. In 30 Sekunden hat sich die Welt verändert. Es fing alles so schön an. Ich dachte, es sind ja nicht so viele Zutaten vor allem. Butter. Sehr viel Butter, bisschen Zitronensaft, Wasser und Ei. Das ist ja so sounddates. Ei oder Eigel, und dann, ich habe auch die Regel gehabt, normalerweise, es gibt keine guten Köche, es gibt nur gute Rezepte.
Und diese Regel muss ich jetzt einfach mal, da war ich falsch.
Okay.
Als Vanilltum.
Streichst sie aus deinem Regel.
Ich bin lange Zeit in die falsche Richtung gegangen.
Streichst sie raus.
Und dann habe ich tatsächlich angefangen, diese Soße und Dels zu machen.
Und es fing alles gut an.
Und dann habe ich schon gemerkt, irgendwann, als ich angefangen habe, das Eigelb mit Wasser zu vermengen, und dann stand in dem Rezept, nicht zu heiß machen, sonst wird es Rührei. Und du dachtest dir, Rührei ist eigentlich ganz geil. Ich dachte mir, Rührei ist ganz geil, dachte mir aber, nee, aber ich will ja Hollandaise machen. Also nicht zu heiß, weil sonst hätte ich ja Rührei, und Rührei ist nicht gleich Hollandaise. Also kein Rührei. Also ich mache jetzt ein bisschen Rührei, aber für den Weg, aber danach Hollandaise. Ich mache mir jetzt das, das ist für mich, ein für mich, so soll ich das für euch. Hey, Natalie Portman, ein für dich, ein für mich. Was war Anulation? Für dich. Nee, aber bei Natalie Portman? Ja, das war ein großer Blockbuster, das ist für dich. Das ist für mich, ja. Also für uns. Und für sie war zum Beispiel ihr Indie-Zeug, was ihr anschaut. Nein, Black Swan war auch für dich. Ja, eben. Ja, das, was für sie ist, sehen wir nicht, weil es für sie ist, halt so Indie-Zeug. Wie für sie? Macht sie privat oder was? Nein, aber halt so, was sag ich mal, aber Garden State kennt man ja auch. Ja, das war ja vor ihrem Durchbruch. War das für sie? War mit ihrem Durchbruch. Nein, sie macht auch Filme, die ihrem Star-Level nicht angemessen sind. Also Star Wars 2 und Star Wars ist total für dich. Ist für uns. Ja, nicht für sie. Was ist denn für sie? Filme, die wir nicht kennen. Ja, aber Garden State ist doch auch für sie. Nein, wir kennen doch auch Garden State war ihr Durchbruch. Aber wir sind doch auch in ihrer Blase ein bisschen. Nein. In die Blase. Gunstate kannst du doch nicht einordnen, weil das vor dieser Ich und der. Zurück zur Hollandaise. Und ich muss sagen, ich habe die Hollandaise unterschätzt. Es war ein Riesen, es war so. Dann beginnt es nämlich, weil dann dachte ich mir, gut, wir wollen kein Rührei, wir wollen aber auch nicht rohes Ei. Okay, okay. Und jetzt darf es nicht heiß, es darf nicht zu heiß werden. Ich dachte mir aber, wir können ja nicht rohes, ich kann ja nicht rohes Ei für den Grillabend, einfach Leuten zum Frass vorwerfen. Ja, du fährst noch drei Stunden im heißen Auto. Das kann doch nicht sein. Also habe ich das ein bisschen heiß gemacht. Aber dann roch schon so ein bisschen das Rührei. Dann habe ich die Herdplatte runter gemacht, das war schon ein Ritterflera-Rasierklingel. Wie viele Eigelben reden. Von wie vielen Eigelben reden wir? Nur zwei. Okay, okay. Okay, alles klar. Nein, das ist zu wenig. Nein, das ist zu wenig. Naja, ich habe dann, das ging alles gut. Nebenbei hat die Butter, die ich vorher ein bisschen warm gemacht habe, aber nur nicht zu mehr hitzen, weil es uns gerinnt ist, habe ich auch gelesen. Machen Salat, Stefan. Ja, die nächste mache ich einen fucking Salat. Dann habe ich die abgekühkühlt. Und jetzt musst du langsam, und das ist schon alles dann eigentlich, du musst dann langsam die Butter, dem Eigelb, was eigentlich, machen wir uns nichts vor, rohe Eier sind, hinzugießen. Ja. So, und das habe ich auch gemacht. Und dann plötzlich sah es super aus. Dann habe ich Muskat hinzugemacht, dann habe ich Salz hinzugemacht, Pfeffer hinzugemacht, es hat perfekt geschmeckt. So, und dann war der Grill noch nicht ganz fertig. Da dachte ich mir, ja, ist ja scheißegal. Und dann gehe ich so raus zum Grill, frage, ist der Grill fertig? Nein, ist noch nicht fertig. Ich sage, ja, ist ja scheißegal, gehe zurück zu meiner Hollandaise und ich höre schon aus der Küche, irgendwas ist falsch gelaufen. Irgendwas ist gerade schief gelaufen, weil es laufen schon mir schreiend Leute entgegen aus der Küche. Und dann gehe ich zu meiner Hollandaise und sehe, dass die Ursache des Grauens, sie ist geronnen. Aber es war wirklich innerhalb von zehn Sekunden sah das aus wie Couscous, wie Reis, so bröckelig, das war so widerlich, das sah so schrecklich aus. Daneben lag noch der Löffel, mit dem ich das probiert habe,
die Sauce Hollandaise, bevor ich rausgegangen bin.
Und es war wunderschön, es ist ja eigentlich nur Butter,
muss man einfach mal so zu sagen.
Und es schmeckt einfach ganz gut, automatisch,
muss nicht viel dafür machen.
Und dann komme ich wieder und es ist furchtbar,
weil ich habe sogar ein Bild für dich jetzt,
das können wir vielleicht mal auf die Puffer-Pedia hochladen.
Ein paar Leute haben das dann auf den Spargel gemacht, nur um es mal zu sehen, wie es so wirkt. Oh, Alter! Also mit diesem fallischen Spargel tut das echt nicht. Jesus. Das sieht einfach aus wie flüssige Butter. Also bröckelige, flüssige, bröckelige, abgelaufene Butter. Oh, das war so widerlich. Wirklich, noch nie hat sich ein Grillabend so schnell aufgelöst. Aber was für ein Selbstbewusstsein du hast. Ich würde nie etwas, etwas, das ich noch nie für mich gekocht habe, für andere kochen. Never ever. Das Risiko ist viel zu hoch. Wenn ich ein Gericht zehnmal schon einigermaßen hinbekommen habe, dann für andere. Aber nicht das erste Mal ein Gericht für andere. Das ist doch... Wie gesagt, was machst du denn? Ich habe an meine Regel gedacht die ganze Zeit, es gibt keine guten Köche, es gibt nur gute Rezepte. So, wie lautet die Regel jetzt? Es gibt nur gute Köche. Und wenn du kein guter Köchkoch bist, lass es. Nimm die Tomi. Nimm die Tomi. Hier kommt der Genuss. Hier kommt der Genuss. Bei mir kam nicht der Genuss. Aber apropos Profopedia, da findet ihr dieses fantastische Bild und noch viele andere, denn wir haben die Hausarbeit hochgeladen, die wir letztes Mal besprochen haben, wir haben einige Briefe von Linguisten bekommen, die uns darauf hingewiesen haben, dass das H mit Kreis kein H ist, sondern ein Ein- und Ausatmen. Was ist noch weirder? Also H-Kreis ist, glaube ich, Ausatmen und Kreis H ist Einatmen oder andersrum, keine Ahnung. Und das auf jeden Fall. Jetzt machen die Sätze noch weniger Sinn. Warum atmen wir denn während wir sprechen ein?
Ja, ich weiß es auch nicht genau.
Niemand spricht so.
Wir haben eine überraschend grosse linguistische Community bei uns.
Von daher, die Hausarbeit könnt ihr euch jetzt runterladen auf der Puffopedia.
Und es gibt auch eine andere Hausarbeit, die bei uns geschrieben wurde.
Wollte ich gerade sagen, wir haben jetzt eine Hausarbeit,
wir sammeln jetzt alle Hausarbeiten, die über uns geschrieben wurden,
auf der Puffopedia unter dem Artikel Hausarbeit.
Da muss ich jetzt wieder eine Autorin.
Und diesmal aber nicht aus der Linguistik, sondern ich glaube, aus irgendwas anderem, wie so Kommunikations- oder irgendein anderes Quatschfach halt. Ein Brabbel-Schwafelfach. Falls ihr... Was ist H-H? Das ist dann halt großes Einatmen. Also das ist immer so, dass es halt je häufiger der Buchstabe, desto größer. Und ich glaube, es ist Maximus drei H, danach es geht gar nicht. Was ist Seufz? So ein trauriger Sway. Aber falls ihr noch Hausarbeiten über uns geschrieben habt, dann schickt sie uns, weil wir würden sie gerne alle sammeln. Und falls ihr mal an einem Samstag Nachmittag irgendwie nicht wisst, was ihr machen sollt, dann lest euch auf Puffopedia oder macht was anderes. Mach was anderes. Ich werde momentan auf der Wikipedia geghostet. Wirklich jetzt? Was heißt das? Ich werde mehr oder weniger ignoriert. Also und zwar, ich habe mir meinen Artikel geschrieben und dann kamen da viele Kritik und dann habe ich die Kritik geändert und dann den Artikel noch erweitert. Du hast deinen Artikel geändert. Ich habe den Artikel auf Grundlage der Kritik geändert. Und dann habe ich noch einen weiteren Absatz hinzugefügt und aber es gibt anscheinend, können Admins einen Artikel dahingehend flaggen, dass Änderungen nicht mehr automatisch veröffentlicht werden, sondern erst abgenommen werden müssen. Und der erste Kritiker, der bei mir die Kritik geschrieben hat, der ist das und der hat das so gepflegt. Weil Heinrich Himmler 94 offensichtlich nicht wollte, dass das veröffentlicht wird. Und jetzt ist dieser neue Absatz immer im Wikipedia-Limbo gefangen, weil dieser eine Scheiß-Admin, der mich nicht mag, der mich persönlich nicht mag, den nicht abnimmt und deswegen für immer und ewig mein Artikel unvollständig bleibt. Also Subtext, diese Aussage gerade war, dein Wissen bleibt der Menschheit verwehrt, weil es eine Wissensdiktatur bei Wikipedia gibt. Richtig, richtig. Und weil der mich nicht mag, weil es arrogante Arschlöcher sind. Weil es nach Nase geht. Was ja auch clever ist. Wikipedia basiert ja auf Vertrauen. Und Vertrauen ist nur ein nettes Wort für, halt die Arschlöcher möglichst fern. Wenn man mal sagt, es basiert auf Vertrauen, also nichts hat funktioniert, was uns auf Vertrauen basiert. Wenn eine Staatsform auf Vertrauen basiert, dann ist sie zum Scheinern verurteilt. Vertrauen heißt, mach die Klugen stark und die Dummen schwach. Im Grunde ist das Vertrauen, weil dann können wir allen vertrauen. Und Wikipedia ist ein bisschen elitär. Ja, aber auch zu Recht, weil wenn da jeder Depp irgendwas reinschreiben würde, müsste man ständig editieren, deswegen bin ich der Schwache. Ich werde von denen unterdrückt, weil die mich für die Gefahr von Wikipedia halten. Ja. Und das ist echt ein scheiß Gefühl. Kann man den Typen mal public shamen? Nee, das möchte ich nicht. Nee, ich weiß, man möchte es nicht. Ich will ihn jetzt nicht in den Pufo-Linguisten-Mob an den Hals werfen. Wahrscheinlich wird er drei nette Mails bekommen. Also, ist ja nicht so, dass wir irgendwelche Trollen unter uns haben. Er kriegt drei nette Mails und Artikel auf der Puffopedia. Das ist die Reaktion auf die Leute. Das sind unsere.
Und unsere Community würde sagen, getrollt.
Wir haben dich getrollt. Wir waren ja zu Gast im Autokino.
Ja. In einem Podcast von
Max unter anderem, Max Nachtsheim,
Rockstar und Nanu.
Und da waren wir zu Gast und da
bin ich dann, ich wohne in Köln, bin also mit der
Bahn quasi zum Wollmarkt gefahren, dann zum
Glowier. War auf eine Live-Show, ne? War eine Live-Show. Und da kam ich vorbei an den ganz vielen Besuchern der Fibo. Fibo! Der Fitnessmesse in Köln, wo wirklich nur Bodybuilder unterwegs waren. Und ich dachte mir, auf dem Weg zu dem anderen Podcast, der live war, zwei Wochen vorher waren wir auch im Glow-Jahr-Theater, ich war so froh, dass unsere Podcast-Community nicht auf die Fibo-Community getroffen ist. Das stimmt. Boah, das wäre... Holy shit! Oh, das wäre Nitro und Glitzerin. Das wäre so ein Strassenkampf geworden. Ja, mit so ganz viel Schnitten. Bei dem hätten unsere Community keine, machen wir uns jetzt überhaupt keine Schnitte gehabt. Ey, die haben so große Bizeps, die können mit ihren Bizeps schnippen. So wie so West Side Story. Ja. Knack. Krass. Summer Lovin. Nee. Ah, die Fibo, die machen alles fertig, oder? Eigentlich ist Muskel die beste Investition, die man machen kann. Weil wenn wir uns Klimawandel anschauen, die Menschen werden mehr Zeit mit weniger Kleidung verbringen. In der Zukunft. Das heißt, also nicht in Kleidung investieren. Gucci, Gabbana, hier diese ganze H&M, Scott. Ja, da kennt sich jemand aus. Weg mit den Aktien, Aktien hin zu Sonnencreme, Bodybuilder, Macfit, Surfbretter, so ein Zeug, nee eben nicht, Selbstbrenner brauchst du halt nicht mehr, wenn es heiß ist den ganzen Tag. Das ist richtig. Deswegen verdienst du kein Geld an der Börse. Und deswegen Leute, investiert in, nicht eure eigenen Muskeln, machen Sie es vor, investiert in fremde Muskeln. Jetzt Hamsterkäufe, Proteinpulver, Hamsterkäufe, Handeln. Na gut, ist schwer. Aber ganz viele Hamsterkäufe, einfach Gewicht, Steine, Lage. Diese ganzen Proteinläden, wo nur Protein, wirklich kistenweise Proteine. Wo nur schwache Menschen. Die sind auch oft gut, die schwache Menschen besitzen, diese Läden. Und diese Läden sind oft pleite. Da ist danach oft dann, da ist dann andere, halt was danach in ist. Danach ist dann halt ein Vape-Laden da drin. Und danach ist halt dann was Pokémon-Go-Laden. Es gibt so manche Läden, die sind einfach so saisonal, wo immer alle paar Monate also erst hast du Bubble Tea, dann hast du den Fidget Spinner-Laden, dann hast du den Protein-Laden, dann hast du den Booster-Bord-Laden, dann nochmal Bubble Tea- Tea laden, dann Frozen Joghurt, dann hast du irgendwie so Federstäbe, wo du so rumspringen kannst. Skaterladen, Finger Skate, dann Fidget Spinner, dann Cube Spinner. Oft auch Läden, wo gar keine Regale mehr sind, sondern einfach Kisten, wo die sich auch keine Mühe geben. Und die dann einfach nur so eine Schaufel haben und das Produkt so rausschauen. Das war nämlich hier, ein Kiosk hat gesagt, what Fidget Spinner, hat auch viel so später davon gehört leider,
und hat einfach sehr viele Kisten hingestellt mit Fidget Spinnern.
Nichts ist trauriger anzusehen als zu späte Investitionen.
So, Marianne, jetzt die Fidget Spinner und dann noch drei Kisten und das ist 2019 und du so,
ja, wir haben jetzt runtergesetzt von fünf Euro auf fünfzig Cent und wenn du mehr nimmst, dann 10 Cent pusht. Das ist so traurig. Das ist so traurig. Das ist so traurig. Naja. Weil eigentlich musst du Unterhändler sein. Du musst nicht einen Endkunden, du musst der Unterhändler sein. Der, der damit Geld verdient, dass andere Leute Geld verdienen wollen. Weil der verdient am meisten am Hype, glaube ich.
Weil plötzlich ganz viele Läden Fidget Spinner haben wollen.
Und deren Hype hält auch länger per Definition.
Weil ja erst die Nachfrage der Kunden sinkt und dann sinkt das Angebot.
Ist ja verzögert.
Das heißt, du machst mehr Geld als Zwischenhändler, denn als Endkundenhändler.
Also du musst in Vertrieb.
Stefan, du musst in Vertrieb. Stefan, du musst in Vertrieb. Du bist immer noch hier, du bist nicht im Vertrieb. Ich bin nicht im Vertrieb. Ich werde nicht glücklich im Vertrieb. Klar, Vertrieb ist das Beste. Hast du schon mal im Vertrieb? Ja, mal so ein paar Boxen schieben, so ein paar Klemmbretter ausfüllen. Das ist mein Leben. Dann bist du auch nicht Vertrieb. Klar, Lagerist, mal so richtig viel Zeug haben. Lagerist macht mehr als DHL-Paketshop-Besitzer. Ja klar, Lager, ich glaube, Lager sind die beste Investition. Warum denn Lager jetzt? Naja, weil viel mehr Sachen halt übers Internet mit Delivery und so und irgendwann kommen diese Drohnen, die das dann hin und her drohen. Weitere Plus, Gabelstapler fahren. Ja, brauchst du glaube ich in der Zukunft nicht mehr. Da hast du so Laufbänder und so Roboter-Systeme. Aber du brauchst die Räume. Es gibt so ein Technikmuseum in Dortmund, wo ich sehr oft war. Und da konnte man angeblich rückblickend, feuer Quatsch, da hast du halt so einen Gabelstapler-Simulator gehabt. Da konntest du dich reinsetzen, da war vorne Bildschirm, hinten Bildschirm, links und rechts Bildschirme. Und dannntest du halt rumfahren so ein bisschen und dann hast du als wie man halt, wenn man nach Gold gräbt in Freizeitparks, da kriegst du nach so eine Medaille, Goldgräber und man denkt als Kind, boah, geil, ich bin Goldgräber.
Hä, die ist, natürlich ist es wert.
Die ist nichts wert.
Klar, hallo, ich habe drei Stück davon.
Das ist kein Gold.
Das ist meine komplette Zukunftssicherung. Du hast keine Lande nach Gold gegraben.
Da steht Nummer eins drauf, hallo, weißt du was wert ist?
Du bist nicht der Erste, vorhin waren noch andere Kinder in der Reihe. Die haben auch Nummer eins gehabt. Habt ihr nicht verglichen die Münzen? Hat dir reingebissen, hat dir den Biss-Test gemacht? Nein, das sei dann wertlos. Und genauso wenig ist offensichtlich, habe ich erfahren, dieser Gabelstapler-Führerschein wert. Nur, dass du damit in große Schwierigkeiten kommen kannst, weil ich auch bis in ein Erwachsenenalter gedacht habe, ich habe echt einen Gabelstapler-Führerschein. Weil warum sollte man das sonst behaupten? Das ist saugefährlich. Du kannst dem Kind doch nicht sagen, du hast einen Führerschein jetzt da drin. Deswegen bin ich dann oft einfach mal mit Gabelstapler durch die Gegend in den Block gefahren. Als Vierjähriger und dachte mir, das kann ich ja machen. Ich glaube, benutzen Fahrschulen heute eigentlich auch Simulatoren so? Nee. Doch, ich glaube schon, oder?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, irgendwas habe ich gesehen, irgendwas, wo ich dachte mir, ah ja, stimmt, die nutzen bestimmt Simulatoren.
Und dann haben sie auch Simulatoren benutzt.
Ich glaube, es waren Soldaten.
Und zwar, Formel-1-Fahrer benutzen quasi auch das Spiel, was man spielen kann, um besser zu werden in Formel-1.
Ach echt? Die zocken dann ganz Tourismus?
Nein, die zocken vielleicht nicht Need for Speed, sondern dann vielleicht eher Formel 1 2018. Hauptsächlich für die Musik eigentlich. Hauptsache wegen des Soundquests. Nicht fürs Fahrgefühl, sondern für die Musik. Und die sitzen ja auch manchmal in Simulator und fahren dann vorher die Strecke ein paar Mal. Und die sind auch sehr gut. Da kann man ja manchmal, haben die ja dann diese Test, diese Geister Fahrten gemacht. Dann musst du die halt bei Zeit fahren, manchmal musst du die einholen. Und dann siehst du halt, Sebastian Vettel ist diese Strecke auch schon mal gefahren und der fährt ja davon. Aber jetzt weiss man auch nicht, ob die dann nicht ein bisschen gemogelt haben, weil der ist doch auch, wenn er zum ersten Mal dieses Spiel spielt, mit dem Controller in der Hand, auch nicht besser als ich. Oder? Ich dachte immer, Formel 1 ist Bullshit, bis ich wirklich mal selber ein Rennspiel intensiv gespielt habe und einfach gemerkt habe, wie viel Zeit man durch gutes Fahren rausholen kann. Seitdem habe ich großen Respekt vor denen. Ja, du musst aber den Kurven Scheitelpunkt erwischen. Ja, oder die anderen halt wegrammen. Und das ist das ganze Wissen, was man braucht. Oder halt die anderen wegrammen. Nein, wenn du den Scheitelpunkt erwischst, behaupte ich, musst du nicht mehr wegrammen. Das war mein Formel 1 Tipp, fallsTipp, falls ihr am Wochenende vom Lines-Fagen sitzt. Warte. Dann freut euch auf die nächste Folge, die kommt nächste Woche. Nochmal vielen Dank an Moritz für das fantastische Intro. Wir haben so fantastische andere Intros. Nichts wie Moritz, aber da kommen noch ein paar Highlights. Wir haben ziemlich coole Intros, vielen Dank für alle, die auch noch weiterschicken und wir freuen uns natürlich auch immer über weitere Hausarbeiten. Ansonsten schaut euch mal um auf der Puffipedia
und in Stefan Tietzes Blog,
stefan.de
und ansonsten macht's gut. Bis nächste Woche,
wir heben ab und sagen Tschüss. Tschüssi!
Warum heben wir immer ab und landen aber nie?
Warum landen wir nie?